protests against russia's invasion of
ukraine have filled city streets around
the world
but this one feels different it is
russians protesting against russia
i feel devastated i feel mad
i feel helpless
every day i wake up i read the news i
cry i have family
in russia and in ukraine
and um
i just i don't know
i i i feel awful
just here in new york there are an
estimated 500 000 russian-speaking
immigrants and most of them live here in
this neighborhood of brooklyn at this
protest they are all united on one
mission to end the war
when i see people's
blood peoples
tears
most of the russians who are
in russia
they don't see the reality
they think that this is all like a
funny movie it's not true people need to
know the truth
that it's a real where war
and we need to stop it
now yesterday what goes through your
mind when you see your country attacking
another country that's that's that's
pain deep deep pain and
fear
so it's something like
i don't know
like like i'm from nazi germany from
second world war time
it's it's
unbelievable like
i can't believe it
it's happening right now
and i'm in pain
words and feelings of russians watching
from afar and asking why vladimir putin
ordered this invasion
and demanding he stop but fearful he
isn't listening
gabriel lozando al jazeera new york